Andy and I are going to start out
by taking a few measurements.
>> So, what we have are two circles.
We've got a big one,
which is a bike tire.
And we've got a little one,
which is a pie.
>> We're going to be
measuring the circumference,
which is the length all the way
around the outside of the circle.
And we're also going to be
measuring the diameter,
which is the length across the circle.
>> All right, so
let's start with the bike tire, and
measure it's circumference.
I'm going to start here and
go all the way round.
Thanks for helping, Rachel.
And there we go.
Now I'm going to measure the length
of this using the tape measure.
Or, Rachel will.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, and it's 88 inches.
I'm going to write that down.
>> Okay, so now let's measure
the circumference of the pie.
And again, I'm going to start here and
ask Rachel to help hold it.
And go all the way around.
All right, and
when we measure the length of that.
>> Okay, and that's 28.25 inches.
I'll write that down too.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> And now, let's measure
the diameter of the bike tire.
Looks like it's 28 inches.
And the diameter of the pie
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Is about nine inches.
Now that we've measured
the circumference and
the diameter of both the bike tire and
the pie, it's time for a quiz.
Divide the circumference
by the diameter for
both the tire and the pie and
do your answers here.
Round to two decimal places.